[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au Centre national du
football de Clairefontaine je suis Éric
latronico le directeur du Centre ce site
mythique permet d'accueillir et
accueillir à travers les temps depuis
maintenant plus de 30 ans différentes
sélections nationales les différentes
équipes de France qui sont succédées
c'est pas loin de 16 à la sélection
nationale qui sont venus sur le centre
dont bien évidemment l'équipe de France
A qui prochainement jouera sa prochaine
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et maintenant on
va aller faire un petit tour sur le
centre pour pouvoir voir les coulisses
et voir comment l'équipe de France va
pouvoir se préparer pour cette Coupe du
Monde suivez-moi
[Musique]
et nous voici maintenant devant la
résidence de l'équipe de France cette
mythique résidence qu'on appelle le
château lieu de résidence de l'équipe de
France et de préparation évidemment
c'est divers événements et la prochaine
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et quand on
parle du château bien évidemment on
parle de ces marches ces fameuses
marches lieu de prestige puisque c'est
là c'est marche qui permettent
d'accueillir les joueurs pour la
première fois dans la résidence de
l'équipe de France qui vont pouvoir
découvrir ce bâtiment lorsqu'ils
arrivent sur le site
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le salon et mes Jacquet est un espace
qui permet d'accueillir les joueurs qui
est une zone de loisirs finalement donc
une zone d'échange qui est propice pour
créer le collectif où les joueurs vont
pouvoir passer du temps ensemble rigoler
discuter jouer donc vous avez un
baby-foot les joueurs aiment bien
pratiquer vous avez une table de
ping-pong également qu'on vient
installer ici et puis les joueurs aiment
particulièrement jouer aux cartes
également donc c'est un l'occasion pour
eux de se retrouver et d'échanger
ensemble espace ici les particuliers
c'est un petit bureau qui permet au
coach de pouvoir s'isoler avec un ou
deux joueurs pour pouvoir parler
tranquillement à l'abri des regards
préparer des aspects tactiques
techniques avec les joueurs à chaque
rassemblement dès lors que les joueurs
se retrouvent on va diffuser en boucle
sur les différents écrans que vous
pouvez voir
les derniers matchs de nos futurs
adversaires donc typiquement pour la
prochaine Coupe du Monde ce sera le
match de l'Australie dernier match de
l'Australie qui sera diffusé pour que
les joueurs puissent s'en imprégner et
puissent voir un petit peu comment
évolue l'adversaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque joueur a une chambre individuelle
qui lui est attribué par le coach comme
vous pouvez le voir elles sont
confortables sans rien d'ostentatoire
mais l'objectif c'est que les joueurs
puissent préparer dans les meilleures
conditions avec une attention
particulière sur la literie bien
évidemment pour que les joueurs puissent
dormir le mieux possible chaque joueur a
sa propre chambre et donc est celle dans
sa chambre
[Musique]
voici dans la zone de récupération donc
c'est un lieu essentiel évidemment polar
récupération des sportifs ce que cette
salle elle permet d'accueillir les
joueurs et de récupérer après
l'entraînement de récupérer après les
matchs pour pouvoir être performant dès
le lendemain ou l'île sur le lendemain
donc on va retrouver différentes zones
où vous avez une zone ici technique avec
des appareils de musculation de cardio
qui permettent aux joueurs de récupérer
vous avez une zone également humide avec
des bassins un bassin d'eau froide et un
bassin d'eau chaude pour favoriser la
récupération entre les entraînements et
également une zone technique plus pour
la partie soin et massage pour la part
des kiné
[Musique]
chakra semblement bien évidemment il y a
toujours un passage par la case
conférence de presse et ses conférences
de presse se déroulent ici dans cette
amphithéâtre faire en Sastre de 250
places avec en contrebas
l'estrade où on va se positionner
l'entraîneur et les joueurs avec la
presse pour pouvoir interviewer
l'ensemble des protagonistes
[Musique]
nous terminons cette visite par le
terrain qui se trouve derrière moi qui
est le terrain
Fibaro terrain d'honneur de l'équipe de
France avec une tribune de 500 places
c'est là où les supporters peuvent venir
acclamer l'équipe la soutenir et puis
les journalistes également lorsque les
entraînements sont ouverts aux médias
beaucoup de joueurs depuis 1988 vous
avez quand même un grand nombre de
joueurs de haut niveau qui sont passés
ici ne serait-ce que pour citer Thierry
Henry par exemple mais vous avez
également pu récemment des joueurs comme
Kylian Mbappe comme Antoine Griezmann
comme Paul Pogba qui viennent
s'entraîner ici après cette visite nous
allons en terminer donc vous voyez
l'équipe de France va arriver
prochainement se préparer pour le Qatar
on va passer deux jours ici au Centre
national du football avant de pouvoir
s'envoler pour cette prochaine Coupe du
Monde et allez les bleus
[Musique]